in type en indonésie comme chez au
vietnam
jaba en chine comme colonne au perron
s'il vous est déjà arrivé que votre reee
adhèrent et caramélisées au fond de
votre casserole
sans le savoir vous avez créé le début
de ces plats en corée c'est le nour une
j ai en iran on l'appelle pas dit c'est
quelque chose que tout le monde adore
adore c'est dans le fond c'est pas un
plat le tabligh
c'est le résultat de la cuisson du riz
etc le croustillant dans le fond de la
casserole et reid m'a sonné a grandi
dans un quartier multiethnique de
montréal
passionné de culture perse et l'a ouvert
son restaurant en s'inspirant entre
autres de la cuisine de l'iran j'ai
connu la bof iranienne depuis que
j'étais tout petit et j'ai adoré et
après ça fait 13 ans maintenant que j'ai
rencontré mon job qui est iranien des
ingrédients simples composent le trading
du riz basmati du sel du beurre clarifié
de l'huile et de l'eau parfumée au
safran après avoir bien rincer le riz
ont fait une première cuisson d'environ
trois minutes pour l'attendrir puis
c'est parti pour la préparation du thé
digue
bref ça devient le plus chaud que
possible mais rajouter quelques pour le
goût et la couleur
erwin ajoute avec prudence de l'eau
parfumée au ça prend des mamans pour
recommencer à une première couche de riz
pour couvrir le fond de la casserole
ensuite on ajoute le reste en formant
une pyramide et on la connaît on les
sarries quelques minutes sur le maximum
là ça va prendre à peu près quatre
minutes comme ça qu'on commence
si jamais on n'est pas ce qu'on a mis à
ces faits ils ont prêté leur niveau on
veut tous nés à cuirieux riz à la vapeur
donc j'étais petit trou et je veux juste
tout doucement verser le mélange d'eau
chaude et de vol qualifié
ça va et puis ça va par un peu plus de
vapeur et il le vert va faire un tas
donne un bon goût en fait après quelques
minutes
irène n'ajoute linge de table afin que
la vapeur soit absorbée pour ne pas
retomber dans laurie il le reste de la
cuisson ça va être au fût le plus bas
par la regarde ces nouveaux jets au
fonds de casseroles
à la manière coréenne maintenant pour
jade ses eaux du restaurant sam le
neurone j n'a plus de secret et tous les
rapports où trouver le doo ri christien
écurie au fonds de casseroles et on doit
trouver la façon pour manger ça on
retrouve le nouveau logis dans le fond
de la casserole et ont servi à cuire le
riz par la suite les coréens ont
l'habitude de faire une infusion à
partir de cette croûte en y versant de
l'eau c'est comme de thé génois bois de
thé après repas mais coréenne au bois le
loup dit le sud de neurologie comme
adultes et on peut facilement faire
d'une ruelle j à la maison c'est doivent
le manx pour fait beau aujourd'hui j'ai
mis un peu raté vraiment minimum ça
prendra cinq minutes après vous pour
tourner cette méthode tracé mais ne
savait trouver bombe rouge et après
comme pour l'état digues et rania cette
route de riz s'utilise de plusieurs
façons en accompagnement ça c'est le
sauter s'effrite mais surtout aux
légumes et en faut au fonds de
casseroles il ya lenovo chine
le plat le plus populaire chez les
coréens et le bim bam une fois le riz
est allé au fond de la poêle de pierre
tous les ingrédients sont ajoutés pour
ensuite laisser cuire sur le feu de
cette façon le nouveau logis se formera
au fond c'est vraiment le meilleur mais
part de bing maps
après manger gras était le duriez au
fond c'est bon de retour chez et run
après environ 60 minutes de cuisson
c'est l'heure de vérité que c'est beau
voilà le têt digue laisse voir sa belle
couleur carré miniser est-ce que ça
ressemble août à vous et vous avez marre
de le faire me tadic pour laquelle on se
battait quand on était jeunes peut-être
jour qui peut s'asseoir ou me rendre
autour de la table pour peut-être avoir
une chance de passer devant et là vous
ne le servez avec quoi qu'est-ce que
vous avez assez des terrains plats
traditionnels qui s'appelle le fait
saint john c'est un braisé qui vient du
nord de l'iran c'est
pomme grenade et
noix de grenoble avec des petites
boulettes d'agneau
c'est vraiment très bon et sept textes
sur leurs étudiants pour nous c'est
vraiment le summum de ce partage assez
croustillant trotter borie ben merci de
nous faire voyager comme ça cet accord
visait